[Music]
oh hello
I'd like to play a game
perhaps one of the addresses those
sticky
I've had my eyes on you and I do not
like what I see
your job as a custodian is a noble one
sanitizing and sterilizing the hospital
helping patients avoid sickness but
there is a sickness inside you that
needs to be exercised you have the
ability to not only save your soul today
but your sight
all you have to do is click the dial
across the five positions and he will
live to see another day even 60 seconds
helpless
okay
what's up
[Music]
[__]
thank you
[Music]
hahaha
what is it what is it I don't know what
the [__] all of these things are medical
supplies I think and and there's a
[__] bone cutter the great news I
don't care what the [__] things
just just play me I'm not gonna touch
nothing
[Music]
hello Mateo
Gabriella's next
what
sometimes we get sucked into things that
are against our nature drugs are
suspicious
as they are powerful we all have free
will
Gabriella had her own free will
and if you can't handle this how will
you handle the rest of our work
[Music]
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life actually
John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
we all pretended to cure me but what I
have planned for each of you is very
real
the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
you picked John Kramer please don't
hesitate
place a big enough piece of yours or you
blow tissue into the glass enzyme tank
this will save your life
yeah
this is not retribution it's a
Reawakening
[Music]
little dog the choice is yours
foreign
[Music]
months at best I still have a lot of
work that needs to be done
it was our desire to make a film that
feels more like the early Saw movies
this in in our mind is really sought to
this movie happens weeks after the end
of saw one I help people overcome inner
obstacles
it needed to look like the early summer
they were shot on 35 they were scuzzy
and gritty they're you know there's our
cynical greens and ocher yellows we're
working with a cinematographer here who
has just done a fabulous job
one of the great challenges of this
project was really putting together an
excellent trap team and I feel like we
have this amazing team
and I think that the fans are going to
be happy
all the people that really love saw I
want to play a game my job
is to bring Humanity to John Kramer
the traps I leave to the people who are
Disturbed enough to come to come up with
some of these things and we go back to
what I think the audience most enjoys
about John Kramer's character a wage war
a wage war against mediocrity what
struck me was the relationship between
John and Amanda I think that's some of
the best passages or scenes everyone
deserves a chance you should know that
more than anyone it's super
fun to be able to come all the way back
to the beginning
we really did this movie for the fans
the story is compelling and the saw fans
Next Level we really tried to pay them
back for the loyalty and the fans that
have been there since so on and that's
why there's the Easter eggs there's
Throwbacks we just really try to say
you've asked for this movie We're making
this for you
[Music]
thank you